who is angeline
[Music]
i'm something you have to feel
something you have to experience
if you really want to know you have to
come with me
[Music]
angeline is a mysterious woman who
became famous in the 80s when a series
of billboards popped up around la with
her on them who is angeline
the more you don't know the more you
want to know it made you want to find
out who this person was
so the show tries to answer the mystery
of who she is and whether or not the
mystery should be answered who are you
our story spans 60 years from 1959 to
2020
and then the bulk of the scenes play out
as memories
there are points in the show where a
character will have a different
remembrance of what happened and you'll
see both versions of it
it gives you perspectives of everyone
and then you choose how much you think
is real and not real
angeline is a series about identity
about mysteries and what mysteries do to
us when we can't solve them it's a
playful exploration of who la's most
mysterious cult icon truly
is how she goes about getting what she
wants and how all of this is a
reflection on our own relationship to
fame and transformation why are you
famous i'm famous for being on billboard
the first time i saw an angeline
billboard i was 13 years old with my mom
on the way to an audition and i just saw
these breasts and this hair
i think the first time i saw her was
driving around out in her pink corvette
a car is supposed to be
an extension of you your being
i want something fast
when i first saw angeline i was like who
is that and people were like we're not
really sure she created herself through
a very poignant myth of hollywood and
glamour that we keep sort of coming back
to it like moths to the flame
at long last
angeline there was an article that came
out in the hollywood reporter in 2017
that suggested that they had cracked the
mystery of who is angeline hello this is
rick krauss and i work for angeline
please take me off of speakerphone
you're not on
uh yeah sure no problem the article
served as the initial inspiration for
the show the story shed light on how
complicated and dark this person
actually is what i found so fascinating
is she rejected that article as being
her truth she kind of writes her own
rules
she came here on a bus from idaho from
ohio
or she hatched from a spaceship
she's an alien
wildly contradictory stories and does
nothing to correct the record angeline
is always in charge
emmy worked tirelessly on movement and
voice
the little hand gesture is the way she
walks
the first time that i put on all of the
prosthetics
i was kind of liberated from any fear
because it was no longer myself you look
different
angeline is ultimately a power struggle
between angeline and everyone else in
her life who seeks to define her this is
my story
don't you dare try to make it about you
your opinion about her i think reveals
more about you than it does about her
[Music]
the people need angeline's truth which
is larger and pinker and better
[Music]
there is kind of a magnetic pull to the
stories that angeline tells about
herself her version of the truth is a
lot more fun if you want the story of my
life it's on a wall at the corner of
hollywood and vine
it's hard to miss
[Music]
you